- Awesome.
- Thank you!
- Take care.
- My spoken word kind of stuff
has really been the one
thing that these kids,
no matter where I go, freak out over.
So, a lot of people have been telling me
to just do a lot a videos for that.
Post them on Instagram,
Youtube, and all of that.
And again with the quality I'm
just you know, I'm worrying.
- [Gary] That's why you're struggling.
- Okay.
- You've put quality,
your personal subjective
quality on a pedestal.
It is such a cliche
reason people struggle.
- You're gonna have to jump into the pool,
and just see what happens.
In the same way at a macro
level, writing the book itself,
you gotta basically do the
same thing with social.
There's no piece of content
with bad enough lighting,
with bad enough quality,
there's no piece of content
that's gonna take you down.
- [Aija] Okay. So it doesn't really matter
about the lighting.
- Nobody cares about your
brand positioning in real life.
Do you know what I mean,
you are what you are.
Your brand position, you're a human.
You're not a bottled water.
Whatever you put out is your
actual brand positioning.
Do you understand?
Yeah, definitely.
- So I think you're treating yourself
too much like a product,
and I think that's inevitably hurting you
and it's hurting you,
not because of the
authenticity of the content,
but because of the utter lack of content.
Like four to five, six times a week
on Instagram is for what your ambition is
and the fact that your target audience
at least in the beginning, was younger
is just not anywhere close to enough.
- [Aija] Okay, that's very helpful.
And then in terms of Twitter, Facebook,
and Snapchat several times a day as well?
- A hundred percent.
Okay.
- Yeah and Twitter's
awesome because you can just
search people's conversations
and engage in them.
Have you used Twitter's search?
Have you searched bullying or
other social justice issues?
- I have, yeah.
- [Gary] Twitter's a cocktail party.
You can interject yourself into every
and any conversation, and you should.
- Okay.
- The others are more content CMS's
and you put out content,
but I highly recommend that.
- I was doing a lot of
research on VaynerTalent,
and all of the amazing
things that you guys do
and I was wondering at what point
in a person's career do
you suggest approaching...
- [Gary] Something like that?
- Yeah, because I know it's out there.
- Yeah, to me it's when you can afford
to invest $25,000 dollars a month into,
You know, we built it because
we think it's best in class.
And I do think it is, and I think it will
inevitably be commodified.
I think more people will realize its value
and more people will do it,
and more people won't have the
overhead costs that I have.
So I'm sure it will come
down in price over time.
You should be, so for me,
the way to really win is
to have pillar, right?
Book is a pillar, but
it's a historic pillar.
To me a new age pillar is either a vlog
or a podcast and you should
have one or the other.
Period.
To me ironically,
actually this is the first
time I'm saying this.
To me ironically, if you do
not have a vlog or a podcast,
right now
you are just leaving an
enormous amount of opportunity.
You know I guess I'm hedging.
To me it's, you become
vulnerable to not being relevant.
You need to have both
of them, one of them,
or you need to be an actual celebrity.
To me it's the only thing that equals
having a television show, or
being an actor or actress.
It's a pillar, you need a pillar.
Otherwise your social media content
is backdating into
something, or it's rando.
Got it?
- [Aija] So posting spoken word raps
and stuff is not as relevant necessarily.
- Well, I like it 'cause spoken ,
When I hear that that's
what people are reacting to,
maybe you know, either one of two things.
Either you do a vlog, first person
more like Kaycee, less like me.
And you do a spoken word
rap in it at some point.
Or I think it's a great content pillar,
but you should put out one every,
can you put out one everyday?
Yeah, see that's why I like documenting.
- I can do like two a week and
vlogs the rest of the time.
- Correct, and just documenting.
The reason I like documenting or vlogging
is you don't have to do anything
other than live your life.
The reason I like podcasts is
you don't have to do anything
other than interviewing somebody.
So that's the key.
The key is to put yourself in a position
where you can create volume.
So many more young people get involved
in nonprofits, they'll start them,
and then they hit 29,
32, 34, and they're like,
wait a minute, I'd like to make money.
Wait a minute, I'd like to do this.
And they have guilt,
and the have, you know.
And I always tell them
you've done more for bullying
already than 99.999 percent of people.
- Oh I guess my...
last kind of question to you would be
two parts in that, as I,
I'm like in the beginning
and I'm making mistakes and I
would love to get to a place
where you're at one day.
And I'm wondering, one,
how to continue to monetize
something that is not directly
in the business world.
You know it's kind of like nonprofity.
Even though I've done so thus far,
I'm trying to find new ways.
And then the other aspect, just in general
any advice that you have
for someone of my position
trying to climb that ladder
and figure out new innovative ways.
- Yeah I mean, I think you
have to reverse engineer
what you want, so you have to
make a decision between legacy
and financial, and that
changes all the time.
You need financial more in
the beginning always, right?
The ways to monetize are
always through content,
access, and services or product.
So the tried and true
ways to make money exist.
So as you know, you didn't
know this, I didn't know this.
Speaking can be very lucrative.
So you could do just fine
continuing to put out content
whether in book form,
video form, vlog form,
podcast form, Instagram
form, and then just speak.
If you have the ability to speak,
which clearly if you're
still doing it, you do.
I mean you could make six
figures very easily speaking.
Which is very good, especially at 21.
So I think that, you know,
I assume with all this, are
there opportunities to write
another book and getting a better advance?
You know there's that.
I mean look, I always tell
people build your brand
because your brand becomes
the halo on everything.
You get paid more for speaking,
you get paid more for books.
You know there's opportunities
coming to me that I never
could of imagined because my
brand is out there, right?
So I think--
- [Aija] And that's with the vlogging?
- Mmm-hmm.
The podcasts, the blog,
public speaking, interviews.
You know just attention arbitrage.
Right, so, my biggest
advice is to deploy patience
cause you're so young.
You've had a lot happen at
a, in a quick period of time.
You need to contextualize
how much a year and a half
or how much 21 years is in the
overall macro of your life.
And then that slows you down
and you start making better decisions.
- [Aija] Yeah, exactly, it's
that patience that's the key.
- It's the hardest.
You know, you gotta decide what you want.
Do you wanna act?
Do you wanna make 40 billion dollars?
Do you wanna buy a football team?
Do you wanna start a nonprofit?
Do you wanna milk it
and then start a family?
What do you wanna do?
Or at least what do you
believe you wanna do right now?
And then all your decisions
should be based on that.
- Okay, do you suggest making
a plan for the scope of?
- I mean, I think everybody
does their own thing.
I never did, I made one kind of like,
I wanna be a very successful entrepreneur,
and I want other people to know who I am
and that's what I've done.
And I want them to know who I am
because I feel like I have
something good to give.
I think that builds real legacy.
That's why I take random
meetings like this.
You know, you just
provide value, you know?
- I've read that you said
you take all the meetings
all the interviews, even it
gets one hit and one view.
- Yeah, and I did that for years, years.
I never thought I was fancy,
I still don't think I'm fancy, you know?
- Absolutely, that's
great you're being that.
- I think so.
- Thank you so much.
- Cool,
you're welcome so much.
Where were you born, thank you.
- I was born in New York,
and then I moved to
California, but I'm Russian.
- Is that right?
- I am.
(speaking Russian)
I don't speak Russian.
- But you understand it at all?
- Tiny bits.
- Tiny bits, hmm?
- Yeah.
- Was your, were your parents born there?
- My grandparents were.
- Your grandparents, awesome.
- And my dad speaks Russian.
- Awesome, yeah it makes sense.
Awesome, such a pleasure,
have a great day.
- Thank you, can I take
a picture with you?
- Sure, of course.
(tranquil music)